hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play dead
space 3 all right we got a when we last
left off we kick it to ice of a big bad
monster who is not that bigger bad
we made a probe gun then we're gonna
stick into the side of one of those
gigantic monsters for some reason
probably all logical scientific reasons
and then again probably not but anyway
we are persevering it no matter what the
costs and people are trying to tell me
that oh this is a bad idea
alright no it's a bad idea so anyway you
guys have told me I've got scavenger
BOTS mallow you do buddy
oh hello dere you don't in there you
guys oh I'm dying excuse me sorry about
that I did not feel good I already have
a probe gun why would I need another
probe gun I guess I have to probe guns
now alright then
anyway I got plenty of tungsten I need
to make another tungsten bar that's for
definite sure sorry something's stuck in
my throat I don't know what's going on
there um I apologize this is highly
irregular alright so anyway uh you guys
have told me that I need to look at my
blueprints cuz I've got a lot of
different guns here that I could make
but I am often overlooking this to see
but I do not have nearly the materials
required and I do not think that I have
enough ration seals maybe I do
monix uh ah
sixty it went up I is baloney wow this
looks pretty lethal for science
equipment I already noticed do with it I
know this
whoa whoa whoa
I thought I stomped those bodies it's
got actually ain't all that bad ah balls
to you I can't get off of me okay this
gun sucks ass never mind I was wrong hey
looks like I probed them Hey
yeah sorry Dan way sorry I still got
something stuck in my throat I do not
know why and trying to persevere without
stopping ah but I am okay because I am a
rock I will keep going huh so we need to
get oh my god is this really the speed
of this elevator here holy balls no no
thank you I do not want any No
get down
slimy guys how do you come from man
yeah to prayer jeepers
yep I said nope yeah man those little
things are uh no no I just killed you
what the baloney that's not right that's
not right when I kill you I expect you
to stay dead I guess for those in
particular I got a go for headshots so
that oh my god
yeah because there we go pop goes the
weasel all right I hear it I hear it I
hear bring me babe mmm mmm put it down
get it out kid he didn't get it off get
it goin I hear another one I don't have
another one anyway moving forward after
that debacle you think that my teammates
would be in a lot more trouble given
that there are so many of these things
hanging around hey guys
hey hey let's get inside this thing
before I lose my nerve so what needs to
happen here there's a harpoon gun on
either side of the upper catwalk this is
likely how they hoisted the stomach open
uh-huh terrific
I'll head up yeah oh look another
scavenger BOTS coming back yes that's my
other one Bing bong give it every
ordered
I want my ration shields because I need
to buy stuff that's not very many ration
shields anyway I need to what do I need
to do one of the word Hammond's rocket
launcher oh yeah I put that in there
that's right yeah okay did you get rid
of that sure oh that he'll do that call
kid I'll get this out of here what is
this
doing here anyways good duh Isaac our
guys no need for crap Roger Clark lives
efficiently mechamorphs Maggie damaged
or cannot have crap don't worry about it
what what did he do
I did not detect what dick thing that he
did ah he's just generally a dick I
didn't even need to have a reason
anymore
activate bang yeah open up open up big
boy here we go
good enough uh I'm not even gonna put a
bed this thing's gonna come alive while
I'm inside it because I think I'm going
inside it hey lady hello dick hole I
should shoot jump pass out I oh well I
will not
let's see think I'm good yeah
now that he's appropriately spread-eagle
I will just meander my way in you'll
need to ride the cage out to the opening
can you help us
Wow gotta be kidding me I'll save it
I'll go inside I just need you to lower
me down yeah whatever
get in the cage oh that's what I was
already doing
you're such an a-hole I volunteer to do
these things I don't even know where
Ellie's boobs I mean Ellie is don't
don't do anything Shady
don't do anything oh don't do anything
silly
oh my god sign it you grow
bondic so Santos how will this work
exactly
use the gun sensor attached Misha locate
the nerve cluster and then what pseudo
probe is without the booth oh all right
I got such a saleable holla peg finally
something comes right out all right okay
I seem to have talked over her I didn't
need her advice anyway ping wait what
was that a ping or do I keep going I
keep going listening for it what's
inside it this thing is obviously still
alive
oh there God Santos it's moving
don't worry it's quite day oh these
things are never dead
one going on by what up I got from Holy
Bull Jesus right get off of me get off
of me you dick where do you come from
couldn't even see you go away I don't
want any I do not like you things no I
do not want any no not junior coming
over there but your boobs do it you all
just stay the [ __ ] back on we're not
gonna have any problems are we have any
problem get the hell off of me where are
you you're alive are you alright
this thing's got one hell of a defense
mechanism well did it work no the signal
is just a trickle I can't get a fix on
any specific location all right we're
gonna find out a nerve cluster yes good
idea that should boost the signal dog
yeah good idea
why don't you get in here lady I'm
nothing need to find a stronger signal
ping oh yeah okay all right all right
then okay I do not like being in here
and here is badness weak ping man my
ping so low and losing packets all over
the place
oh all right come on come and get me
yeah can I get me everything no yeah
look I want to get out of here how's the
signal that's a bit stronger but one one
one more oh I don't know why nothing
came after me that one time but at that
time but what is that why is that in
there that's some sort of atmosphere for
me to breathe yes that's good how
thoughtful of them
these are wimpy pings there's not much
else to go in here I mean this thing
isn't that big oh I see
goodness let's get out of here
I got the fix on the machines good get
me out of here
gimme I hear where are they where they
now give me that big mess back oh yeah I
don't know
bad I got my case this is my canvas get
my cash yeah ba cage [ __ ] out Oh getting
in the cage was not a good idea
get off of me thank you very much and
now I'm alone I said why musk I said
well much crime it
Jesus this cage is a very bad idea
either I'm getting out of here come on
get up Oh a kid on my way I'm wasting a
bajillion health package oh my god I'm
gonna die
these [ __ ] good God one more
see a toast please tell me you got what
you needed
yes thank you it will take me a moment
to fix two potato fine I'm gonna head
back to the king I'm already in the cage
thank you very much I'm man fighting
from the cage I thought would have been
a good idea because I'm gonna funnel
them there no there we go
I thought that's us we have a fix on the
machine yes there are thousands of
signals all concentrated far below the
planet's surface there has to be it
there's an entrance further up the
mountain that needs a second dig further
up the mountain their sheer cliffs why
so some climbing gear store below Santos
and I will start setting up the base the
clip Norton can you make sure Isaac gets
out safely
sure sure I'll take care hello
I love you you know that right well yeah
I use it the clip Hey yeah of course
come on Norton where's where's um the
other guy
Carver where is Carver at this time
honey it's ele where's Ellie
Norton open the cage
know what if you wanna die here Nash
your chance I'm taking control of this
mission again hey where you going
saving Ally Noi Noi
le can you hear me dammit Jim my signal
well what a dick he stopped me for two
seconds what an a-hole hey what do you
think he was doing
oh but at least now I finally get to
kill disabled I hated him from not from
the beginning I thought he was a cool
guy in the beginning but actually very
quickly turned into a douche as soon as
he started making out with Ellie's boobs
I mean Ellie Ellie's mine who boobs are
mine amici's mine Thank You Billy
alright I don't think I have any better
circuits I don't think I need that
either so let's get back to the rocket
launcher rocket launcher hell yeah oh
wait tonight I used a lot of med kits I
know yeah I'm almost out of bed kids I
can't believe I used that many med kits
while I was in there he was just like I
was in a panic I don't even think I just
sold all of my useless crap Isaac Clark
needs his crap now please please
Isaac Clark need crap please I haven't
use one of my big med kits
oh well them's the them's the breaks
I'm going this way now okay I follow
another med kit thank you very much I
finally get to put the hurt on Norton
and go on my merry way
yeah I'll punch the air just for no
random reason there we go there we go
where I go where I go
wanna kill him I'm gonna kill him dead
I'm gonna kill him so dead but first I'm
gonna upgrade my suit after I get this
and this and then I'm gonna upgrade my
suit and all y'all boy you ain't goin no
pain like you no pain when I'll give you
pain oh hell naw yeah that's what I'm
talkin bout
good alright let's see what else we got
ooh more duration ah piss just clothes
man tungsten is like needed for
everything man glad thing a good thing I
managed to build some of those thing
ababbas tungsten coke rain bars whatever
you called I have no idea but anyway I
need lots of them
this looks good that guy didn't even
have a weapon how is he surviving all on
his own and this is actually quite
creepy in here
hello oh I need the bench you wouldn't
believe the trouble you saved me
nice work what well here is the marker
killer Isaac Clark and here we are the
marker homeworld you know I must admit I
almost didn't believe such a place
existed but thanks to your friend Norton
I finally found it that's how they
followed us through shock space no no he
is a bright one all he wants is Isaac
Carver the rest of us can go home
you've got me let the others go it's a
very difficult thing you know undoing
the damage man has done everything we
touch we contaminate we corrupt the
markers had a plan for us but we took
what should have been a magnificent gift
and perverted it she's a spirit the
[ __ ] I've spent an entire lifetime
trying to undo the damage man has done
fighting earth curves ongoing research
liberating the markers from those
profane testing facilities and now I
just have one problem left to purge all
of you no no no no you promised me a
ship Derek were your deal yes I'm sorry
about that
I can't afford to leave even one of you
left alive
apologies for misleading you captain
okay
here
yeah rocket launcher [ __ ] yeah just open
that door just open the door
wait no oh they didn't open the door
Boosh all right I'm really kind of sad
that Norton didn't actually die there
yeah
come on [ __ ] kidding me
now this is what I'm talking about and
how that hurt because I didn't realize
that I was playing oh bring it you [ __ ]
are you the one that I was inside or you
better be I'm gonna destroy I'm going to
draw you ha ha rocky louder oh no you
don't oh no no no no you little [ __ ]
are the bane of mines in I hate you so
much
bring a [ __ ] coming coming from Boosh
Boosh
I guess pull out on this sumbitch there
we go come on come on I see what I need
a shoot I did suck you down [ __ ] well
you don't like to chase with the
medicine I'm giving you
thanks for feeding me an oboe that's
awfully kind of you
whoops miss me
shut today hole where's Carver better
Carver oh hello
yeah I'm shooting
Oh
sucking your own babies
no-no-no
no no no no no I said no I said now how
was not paying attention to that so
thank you very much my bye bye bye
I did not realize before that I could
preemptively destroy those fish oh come
on don't automatically reload
but I'm having far
Oh
oh man that was grody sorry I wasn't
even paying attention let's just came
back and all of a sudden I'm in a
stomach yeah it isn't normal
shotgun probably much more effective for
these but yeah nailed it rocket launcher
probably even more effective
oh come on oh no you little bastards I
remember these guys ah come on come on
now Boosh
yeah oh here we go more gross stuff
whoa you made us come down here you
would hurts her now look who we are
which we get exceeding Addison whenever
[ __ ] that ones ones heads have we got
you betrayed us I tried to save us you
are the real problem here part not
anymore
captain
[ __ ] come on you won't stay dead forever
not around here what I'm gonna totally
me you tell the truth
now let's go
serves him right
what an [ __ ] who justifies their
actions of betraying their entire you
get some you get the pistols out of you
oh sorry
oh did you want your body not made sure
to turn into an Erica morph oh I'm sorry
I'm doing you a favor by stomping the
piss out of your body your shot chili
huh
I was hoping that I got to do that the
entire time and I'm pretty sure that
everyone in the game the game developers
yeah rah rah I'm pretty sure that
everyone every one of the game
developers knew that ever that we hated
that a-hole and wanted nothing to do
with him so we got to shoot him finally
I don't even care if there was like an
alternate thing that I could have done
to make him survive I don't care I do
not care I would just shoot I would
shoot him again
I Skye sadistic in video game talk I
would shoot him real life now is that
out there
hello can I have that no yes No maybe so
it's outside
I'm in here I'm like her hood where's
window here how do it Oh - damage plus
one reload it's like that joke from the
office if I were in a room with hitler
and someone else in and Toby
Hitler and Toby Oh No Hitler someone in
Toby and I - one bullet two bullets out
I got screwed it up never mind I'm
successful alright so anyway I got one
reloading her damage rate I think it was
I'm not sure which one it was
anyway either way uh who's damaged yes
yes - damage reload - hell yeah all
right dad in there we're good to go
Booya
I don't think there's anything else in
here and there it is hon he won badger
what honey badger oh hey yeah um you
didn't notice the crazy happenings that
were going on over there
Isaac
where's Robert is he
I shot him Ellie
what sorry I had no choice
Norton betrayed us Ellie
he was ready to kill us Isaac did what
he had to do to save the mission come on
we gotta keep moving now there are only
four of us left I do this then we leave
you behind if you can't keep your head
you're a danger to everybody
nobody's leaving anybody oh come on
let's get to the top of this mountain
together together
how is it that in this world of madness
Isaac is the only one who is acting even
a little bit sane besides Carver
I think cars are pulling it together
pretty well but they're not doing too
good over there
yeah anyway wow that sucks yeah what am
i even activating here Oh
grappling hook our ook whoa hello
alright now let's get some action open
this [ __ ] we're gonna start an
avalanche we all try to climb it have a
look around
maybe there's a safer route cuz I am
such badass what the hell is that I
don't think that just me climbing is
gonna cause all of this it's just one
grappling hook
come on as if you can make it you so duh
you're such a badass there we go
easy peasy lemon squeezy okay alright
first rung done
I guess it's designed for co-op here
which I have all alone cuz Isaac Clark
don't need no one who tampered boomer
cap fell - that's right everyone's
waiting on me oh I'll jump right into
the Hat whoops come on Isaac up at the
mountain from the mound
good help miss me is that one gonna
break right in front of me I bet so ya
miss me don't even know why I need to
jump by side straight pretty quickly now
besides I wouldn't feel very confident
about the strength of that grappling
hook if rocks are just falling off
willy-nilly HUP yay oh we made it so
magical up here who actually is kind of
pretty you thing look dad okay I am
actually all out of time so thank you
all someone for watching hoping you're
enjoying this because I am and finally
justice was served so thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye
ah